welcome to the david pakman show i am
jesse dollamore sitting in for david
while he's on vacation listen we got a
problem with conspiracy theories in the
united states it's no longer a fringe
element
that believes that 911 was an inside job
or or that we didn't land on the moon or
or any number of disparate conspiracy
conspiracy theories
the republican party
is
in large measure
led
and motivated by
conspiracy theories
that it is the north star
of the grand old party anymore
and that is evidenced by
their push against science their
disregard for the health and welfare of
their fellow americans and their
families
and i want to talk a little bit about
marjorie taylor green but before i do
i get a lot of flack on my own channel
for talking about
donald trump and and and marjorie taylor
greene and some of these other
q and on adherents and and conspiracy
nutters
and i believe it's important because
conspiracy is what led to
the insurrection at the united states
capital
conspiracy and lies and propaganda is
what led to over 150 police officers
being injured some of them losing
fingers
obviously some of them losing their
lives
so to ignore
these characters
is to bury our heads in the sand
and just hope that it doesn't happen
again
i for one am not prepared to do that
i will continue
to talk about these dangerous
individuals in our country
as long as they exist
now let's talk about
the lovely and talented
marjorie taylor green who is now
suspended from twitter
but still finds places to go to talk
about her insanity
real america's voice
i have been called a not a real american
many times
uh this is the the what i suffer through
i've chosen this profession and i'm
going to be attacked by wingnuts that's
what it is
but to have a network that's real
america's voice
it indicates that there are fake
americans
and i've been called that anyway let's
get to this marjorie taylor green clip
where she rambles for roughly a minute
and 45 seconds
incoherently at times so this is
concerning to me and that's why i'm
saying there's more research needed by
the fda before the fda approves these
vaccines because here's the problem anna
once the vaccines are approved by the
fda fba we are going to see the mandates
for vaccines ramp up
far more than they are right now they're
going to be mandated and i fear they'll
become law in some cities in some states
biden would love to make it the law of
the land
biden would love to make it the law of
the land that everyone is healthy and
their welfare is is attended to
that's her fear
she doesn't fear
that um people are dying
of covet 19.
she doesn't fear that children are now
at higher risk she doesn't fear that her
hospitals are even filling up she'll get
to that here in a minute
she fears that more people will get the
vaccine
that is an unhinged
thought process
and i think that's completely wrong
again i'm not anti-backs i am completely
for people being allowed to make choices
medical choices for themselves and their
families
when you're anti-vaxx
just claiming you're not anti-vaxx
doesn't get it done
margie
you have to actually be
pro-vaccine there's not middle ground
it's like i don't know how i feel about
it
when you go on network after network and
you go on twitter where you have to be
suspended because of your disinformation
campaign
promoting anti-vaccine ideas that's what
makes you anti-vaccine
and i don't think the fda should approve
a vaccine that it doesn't seem to be
that effective especially with covid19
raging all over the country at least
that's what the media tells us every
single day
all right i didn't mean i wasn't wanting
to stop and start this much but listen
two things here she's claiming the media
is claiming that kovid 19 is raging all
over the country
it is true we have statistics we know
what the numbers are we know what the
hospitalization rates are we know what
the infection rates are we know how many
tests are being tested
but
to to to ignore the fact that the reason
kovid 19 is outbreaking everywhere
across the country especially in certain
states arkansas louisiana florida
is because of people like you marjorie
taylor green who are encouraging people
not to get the vaccine
it is overwhelmingly
non-vaccinated individuals who are being
hospitalized and who are dying
still
of the coronavirus
it is irresponsible
it's shameful this is shameful what
we're witnessing in this country the
mismanagement by republican governors
and being being bolstered by by
clowns
like this um but i've talked to local
hospitals here in my district and here
in my state yes the waiting rooms get
full but guess what the waiting rooms
are full um of all kinds of things not
just covet some you know car accidents
trauma
other illnesses cancer and so forth
but they're seeing about 30
of those numbers being coded cases so
while the news tries to tell us the
hospitals are slam packed with proven
that's just not the case everyone needs
to get back down uh back down to common
sense and remember that you know we're
human we we can't live forever we are
going to catch all kinds of diseases and
all kinds of diseases viruses and we get
hurt sometimes um so i i'm all for let's
let's be rational with this let's be
careful let's be cautious and let's not
turn into an authoritarian regime that
forces uh shots and arms of people that
don't want it
remember
during the passage and debates
uh and the promotion of obamacare prior
to its passing
remember the republican conspiracy
theory and the talking point that obama
was going to impanel
uh a group of individuals to choose who
lives and dies because of the ultimate
uh rationing of health care that was
sure to happen
death panels they called them remember
that also remember and note that there
are no death panels and we have
obamacare
but secondly that same republican party
is now
the same oh death panels they're going
to be killing us that same party is now
who cares if your grandma dies snowflake
everybody dies we're human
get used to it
reprehensible
hypocrisy
the the stark lack of empathy
in republicans
is
it seems to me to be
so widespread that maybe it's itself
infectious a contagion that needs to be
dealt with because they don't give a sh
they don't care
about america or americans
all they care about is their grip
on power
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video